comme un petit air de rentrée
universitaire avant l'heure ces lycéens
venus de toute la région vont pouvoir
découvrir le campus dijonnais et ses
différentes filières beaucoup savent
déjà où ils veulent s'orienter oui
j'aimerais aller en fac de médecine en
langues étrangères appliquées c'est leur
licence en histoire autant de filières
où depuis deux ans les étudiants ont dû
composer avec la pandémie cours et
partielle en distance yale jauge en
amphi des conditions d'enseignement qui
si elle devait se reproduire n'effraie
pas les plus motivés on a connu toutes
nos années lycée avec cette pandémie
donc je pense que là on rentre dans un
processus où on est complètement
habitués ça changera pas beaucoup et ce
qui n'a pas changé c'est l'attrait de
l'université de bourgogne qui se vérifie
à chaque journée portes ouvertes on
attire des étudiants d'autres régions on
a aussi des formations d'envergure qui
peuvent aussi attirer des étudiants de
la france entière
l'année dernière les journées portes
ouvertes on avait réussi à avoir des
connexions vraiment de la france entière
voire même à l'international cette année
les futurs bacheliers peuvent échanger à
nouveau directement avec des enseignants
et des élèves des différentes filières
des moments qui avait manqué l'an
dernier l'université ça fait un petit
peu peur parce que les étudiants un peu
l'impression d'être jeté dans un grand
bain dans lequel il pourrait peut se
noyer on est sûrs et les parents et les
étudiants qui en fait c'est pas le cas
on est quand même assez présent les
encadrent pour se faire une idée encore
plus précise de ce qui les attend
pendant les prochaines vacances du 14 au
18 février
les lycéens pourront venir assister à
des cours de l à la fac comme s'il y
était déjà